hey you guys flickers of fear time i
cannot believe it took me so goddamn
long to get around to doing this movie
holy [ __ ] but yeah anyway uh anybody
that knows me
knows that i'm a pretty big fan of uh
jim jarmosh uh not like a superfan or
anything like that you know i haven't
seen every single one of his movies but
i've seen like a good portion of them
and i'm like a really big fan of his
kind of
droll philosophical
laid-back hangout type of movie vibe
sometimes more successful than others
but
um because recently
well but not that recently i guess it
was like a couple of years ago but we
did
actually end up seeing the dead don't
die and we actually uh saw that in the
theater a couple of times because i know
a lot of people really didn't like that
one because they kind of thought maybe
the humor didn't work or something like
that for some reason it just like
[ __ ] tickled me i just like really
really liked it a lot so i ended up
seeing like i said a couple times in the
theater and you know seeing that as that
was like jim germais's take on the
zombie genre using zombies to like kind
of
sort of like portray like a larger
message so obviously
i knew that he had done a vampire movie
back in 2013 called only lovers left
alive and i have had so many people like
over the years recommend it to me and
like i said i was like i promise i'll
get around to it i'll promise i'll get
around to it but then so finally finally
you know it's on amazon prime so i was
like okay god damn it i'm just gonna
like sit down and watch this [ __ ]
movie and like i said why the [ __ ] did i
wait so long to see this movie because
this movie is
delightful i really really liked i
actually really likes this i like this
more than the dead note die and i
actually quite like the dead don't die a
lot uh but this is kind of like a
different vibe this is not if you've
seen it um you know that this is not a
horror movie it's kind of more even
though it's about vampires it's kind of
more like a drama black comedy
but it's very very dry like i said it's
very philosophical like it has a kind of
a lot to say about
immortality about different attitudes
toward life but it's not really i mean
there's blood drinking and stuff in it
but it's not really like a horror movie
so don't go into it like thinking it's
gonna be that because like i said if you
know anything about jim jermus she
doesn't really
you know make movies the way other
people make them so it's kind of like
you know that you're gonna expect
something unexpected i guess or you're
gonna like
you know even if he's taking
a genre that you know like zombie movies
or something like that he's not gonna do
like the same [ __ ] with it that some
normal person would do is you know what
i'm saying
so what you have here
is there are two vampires they're a
married couple uh adam and eve now adam
is played by tom hiddleston although i
believe that michael fassbender was
originally supposed to uh play him but
then he ended up not being able to do it
for whatever reason so uh tom hiddleston
uh took the role instead and tilda
swinton plays eve
now these two i don't think they ever
say
how old each of them are the implication
being that eve apparently is much much
older than adam but adam is at least
like a few centuries old i kind of more
got the impression that eve was maybe
like a thousand years old or maybe like
a little bit older
so but you know it's not super important
but it is kind of important to the
dynamic that eve is like much older than
adam is even though they're both quite
old
there are also a couple of other
characters uh john hurt is in this uh
briefly he plays
and i don't think this is because like i
said this came out in 2013
and i don't think it's the kind of movie
that that you know is like spoiler like
it's like oh my god why'd you tell me
what happened because it's not all that
plot driven like stuff happens in it but
it's more like i said like a hangout
movie like a kind of character study
philosophical
uh type movie so it's not like oh my god
there was this big like spoiler like
like surprise that i spoiled for you or
anything like that
so john hurd is in it and uh he actually
plays christopher marlowe which if you
know anything about you know english
literature or anything like that there
is a theory going around i don't know
how
how i feel about it one way or the other
but that christopher marlowe was
actually the guy that wrote all of
shakespeare's plays which they actually
do um
posit is true in this movie so he's been
around a long time too and he's just
kind of like you know shakespeare was
like a hack and it's like i got all the
you know he got all the credit and it's
like i was wanting to do all the work
and blah blah blah
so there's that whole issue
so basically what you have adam and eve
have been married a very long time still
very much in love they don't live uh
together most of the time
uh he was actually some kind of like
legendary rock star at some point you're
led to believe maybe 50s 60s or maybe
he's been a musician for a very long
time because they make a reference
at some point in the movie that he um
had written like some of schubert's
stuff like you know i just gave him the
adagio and stuff like that so he's so
he's been a musician for a long time but
he's apparently some kind of like
reclusive rock star that was like super
famous because at some points you kind
of see
like these sort of like rock and roll
fanboys like kind of hanging like
they've heard this rumor that he's like
this reclusive that he still lives in
this place and they're kind of like
hanging around like you know hoping to
get a glimpse of him or whatever but
because he's a vampire and he's immortal
obviously um he kind of tries to
stay out of the limelight so he's been
living in detroit um in this just in
this neighborhood that's just basically
kind of like empty um so he's been
living in this kind of like empty
building and he's rigged up uh his own
electricity from uh technology he picked
up from nikola tesla who he knew in real
life because like i said he's been alive
for hundreds of years and uh he
is very much adam's character
is very much mired in the past
he likes to collect old musical
instruments um he has a human
sort of
friend i guess you would call it or you
know overseer or somebody like that but
i don't think um his friend whose name
is ian he's played by uh the late anton
yelkin he i don't think he knows that uh
that adam is a vampire but he just knows
that he's this reclusive rock star rich
dude that gives him like big wads of
cash to go and find things for him so he
brings him like all these guitars and he
like knows when all of them are from and
he seems to like to collect ones from
the 60s and all of the equipment like he
has all this audio equipment in his
house
and it's all old he's a very analog type
of dude and even though he sort of has a
computer he hasn't sort of like rigged
up where
it goes like into like this really
really old like television set
like so he has this all this stuff like
rigged up like i said he's a very analog
type of dude but he's also very much
kind of like a tragic romantic
type of figure where he basically thinks
that
humans have essentially destroyed the
world humanity is circling the drain
you know everything is terrible
so he's very much looking back to the
past as kind of like a golden era and he
doesn't think it's gonna come again
and so he's even got to a point now
where
even though he still writes his music
and he still seems to enjoy it it's like
it doesn't really seem to be
enough to like
get him to keep going so at some point
near the beginning of the movie he
actually gives a bunch of money to ian
his friend and said i want
one a wooden bullet like with a brass
casing but he's like you know i want
wooden inside like the hardest wood that
you can he just wants one of them so you
know you're led to believe that he's
thinking about you know he's
contemplating suicide because he can't
really see
that things are gonna get any better he
doesn't really get any enjoyment out of
life anymore you know he's been around
for hundreds of years he's kind of sick
of it he's over it and all this other
kind of [ __ ]
now contrasted with that is his wife eve
who's played by tilda swinton now she
has been around a lot longer than him um
so perhaps has more of like a long view
or like a longer perspective on history
so she's seen things go into decline but
she's also seen things like come back
and she's seen like a lot more progress
i guess she's seen a lot more history
than he has so she has a very kind of
like zen more positive
view
she's living in tangier and she seems to
still find great joy
in
music and art and reading and things
like that particularly in books because
they show her uh many times like her
just her whole house is just like stacks
and stacks of books and she can like
speed read so she reads every reads
everything very quickly she can read
every language so you know and she seems
to take great delight
in reading and discovering new things
one thing i like too is that she seems
very even though she likes a lot of old
things um she also like keeps up with
the times like she has she packs all
these books and it's like she has old
ones she has new ones and that's like
really cool because she doesn't really
have she doesn't have the same thing
that adam has where he's just kind of
like you know oh there's nothing's good
anymore uh you know what i mean he's
kind of like one of those grumpy like
well it was grumpy like pessimistic it's
like oh everything sucks now blah blah
blah he's one of those kind of guys
whereas she's a lot more
a lot more zen about it where she's just
kind of like you know history is
cyclical um you know things decline but
things also come back there's always
beautiful things uh through every time
period you just have to know where to
find them so she has a lot i guess a lot
healthier attitude toward immortality
than uh than adam does but as i said
they're kind of like two sides of the
same coin and they complement each other
and even after however many hundred
years they've been together they're
still like very very much in love
so they have a discussion
near the beginning like i said she's in
tangier and he's in detroit and they
talk to each other like she has like a
like an iphone and everything and he has
his
rigged up like tv this
cranky old computer and stuff and so
they're talking to each other and she
begins to sense that maybe he's in a
depressive uh episode which she implies
has happened before so she says i'm
gonna fly out there and see you and
uh you know and it'll be i'll try and
cheer you up essentially
so she comes there at that point there's
there's kind of like like i said why i
call this like a hangout movie is just
because for a lot of the movie which i
think is about two hours long i wasn't
really looking at the time like i wasn't
bored or anything but
but it is like a languid languidly paste
let's call it that but like i said it's
kind of like a hangout movie
so they kind of you know she comes to
detroit she thinks it's you know even
though obviously it's detroit and
there's like nobody around and
everything's like ruins and everything
but she still
finds a lot of beauty in it and like
thinks it's delightful and she's like
just interested in everything
and he's just kind of like he kind of is
to an extent but he's always more like
oh well you know they tore this down and
now it's this and it was so much better
before and it was like all this other
kind of stuff so there's a so there's a
while where they're just kind of like
talking just being together to you know
talking about philosophical stuff he's
very very into science he knew like i
said nikola tesla he knew einstein he
knew you know a lot of uh you know
scientists wrote the old days like maybe
isaac newton and stuff like that i don't
remember if he uh had that if he knew
him or not but so he's very into that so
he's always kind of talking about
different scientific theories but but
again that's another
thing where he's you know rolled down
like you know negativity because he's
like you know look at what they did to
all the great scientists over the ages
you know galileo and copernicus and
everybody like that they were just like
persecuted or you know or something like
that or they're still bitching about
darwin like he says at some point so
he's like you know look at what these
humans he calls human zombies um he's
like look at what they've done to like
their best and brightest and it's just
like i don't think it's gonna get any
better
so into this uh situation where they're
just kind of hanging out and she kind of
uh eve kind of twigs onto the fact that
he has actually
purchased a bullet which he's
contemplating using to commit suicide
and that upsets her a great deal
so into this
comes eve's sister ava
now
ava is essentially like the element of
chaos that's introduced into the movie
she is also quite old but she is
essentially like the vampire party girl
right it's like she just wants to go out
all the time and like listen to bands
and all this other kind of [ __ ] now i
should note too that adam and eve even
though they are vampires they don't it's
implied that they don't uh attack and
kill people anymore because what adam
does is he just goes to the local
hospital and he just has this doctor
who's like a friend of his who he bribes
to give him like fresh blood
from the hospital whereas eve in tangier
she has christopher marlowe played by
john hurt uh who has a supplier like you
know a french doctor that can get them
like really good blood because i think
they're worried that i think adam more
than eve that because the planet or
humans are so polluted that their blood
is also polluted and that it's better to
just get it from like a hospital or like
a reputable source so they don't
actually kill people and drink their
blood however
ava seems more open to this uh
possibility like i said she's more like
a party girl she's almost like
um a drug addict but like with blood so
she can't really like control her
craving for it
so she turns up and there's some
implication that the last time she came
to visit them which was uh 87 years ago
i think they say in the film that
something really bad happened although
they never really you know go too much
into what that was
so
she comes there she's very like kind of
you know we need to go out we need to do
this on the other and uh so finally she
gets them to go someplace and uh it
doesn't end up uh in a very good place
like i said i'm you know i i kind of
don't i don't know if i want to spoil
that aspect of the plot
but something bad happens uh at which
point she causes at which point adam is
just like yeah no um she needs to get
the [ __ ] out of here so there's that
whole thing so as the movie goes on like
i said they there's comes a point where
adam can't really hide his location
anymore uh because all of these fans
keep coming there and he really doesn't
want that because he wants to remain
reclusive so eventually they say okay
we're just going to leave everything
you're going to leave all your [ __ ] here
and we're going to go back to tangier
because she's like it's beautiful there
you used to love it um you know it'll
it'll be like we're starting over but
then when they get back
uh there's another problem
with uh their blood supply uh you know
where it's coming from and so they start
to contemplate at the end of the film
that they might actually have to start
drinking blood from humans again
because uh their blood supply source is
you know is running out as i said this
is not
a horror movie but
there was just something about the vibe
of this movie it's just like i really
really loved it's very very gothic it
almost kind of like you know in the best
possible sense where
it's almost kind of it gave me the same
kind of feeling that the you know the
1983 movie the hunger gave me where it's
just kind of like you just want to live
in that world because it's just this
kind of like tragic
romanticism type of vibe and i really
really like vampire movies that are like
that i also like this one because like i
said it's not
a horror movie it's not gory or anything
like that they do show them kind of
drinking blood but they just drink them
out of the wine and everything it's kind
of like your classic you know proto anne
rice type of thing where you know he's
super into like edgar allan poe and and
all this other kind of stuff and he's
just like oh woe is me type of thing but
then she's kind of a lot more you know
as i said
optimistic about it optimistic about the
future it's like you know what i mean
it's kind of like yeah you know things
suck sometimes but you know things come
back i see things bounce back and she
even you know when she first comes to
detroit he just sees it as this kind of
uh you know ruin but that's what he
likes about it is that everything is in
the past and he just wants to wallow in
the past and she says yes but you know
it it will bounce back it's coming back
already see and she points out different
things so it's kind of like exploring
the differences between
people who are more invested in the past
and even if that past is not
uh what happened like it's kind of like
looking back to some fictitious like
golden era and these types of people
like in the modern day like you know
nowadays like seem to be like really
miserable because they always think oh
it was better way back when whenever way
back when was so they're kind of
exploring the relationship between a
person like that
and a person who
is maybe more like i said emotionally
healthy in the sense that they have like
a longer view
of history and they know that things
will like bounce back even if you know
things seem like they suck right now and
it's just interesting that he explored
that theme
through two characters who are vampires
and who are immortal and who have
literally been able to
see all of these historical things have
because they were literally there so
they're using so he's using the trope of
the vampire being immortal to
sort of like explore the idea between
different types of humans and different
types of
ways of looking at the past the present
and the future which i thought like the
more i think about it like the more
brilliant this movie [ __ ] seems like
i said it's not it has a plot in the
sense that like things happen and the
characters do change over the course of
the movie but it's not like a real plot
driven narrative you know what i mean uh
so don't go into it expecting that it's
more like a philosophical
musings on
humanity you know and different views of
history i guess history progress
but seen through the eyes of beings who
were actually
there so who maybe have a different
perspective on it that a human would and
it's you know it's kind of like this
really cool
i saw this one uh review of it
where she was pointing out that adam and
eve were kind of like
two were like yin yang you know what i
mean and they but they just kind of like
fit together perfectly because even
though they are they have very different
ways of looking at the world and looking
at the you know taking the long view of
history and stuff they still like
complement one another and they're still
very much in love with with one another
which i thought was like a really cool
exploration there's also a really lot of
great music in this there's a lot of
great like literary references if you're
into that which you know which i am but
it's not but it's done in a way that's
not pretentious because
even though these two characters you
know knew all of these literary figures
knew all these
you know classical musicians knew all
these writers knew all of these people
and are really into it they're not like
snotty about it even adam's character
who kind of looks down on humans like i
said he calls them zombies and like you
know they're ruining everything type of
thing but even then he doesn't come
across
as like a hipster douche or anything
like that he just comes across as kind
of just like a sad like tragic
figure because you know it it's not kind
of a case where he just thinks he's
better or anything like that so i think
that it's good that i just i the
characters are just so likable even
though on paper it maybe seems like they
wouldn't be because it seems like oh my
god they'd be like so insufferable and
stuff
but they really don't come across that
way they come across like very genuine
you know just likable characters and
this movie is also
quite funny like in in that jimjar moosh
like very dry kind of way which which i
really uh i really dig that you know
it's i was just laughing at like just
little [ __ ] like her having like making
blood popsicles and her being like all
excited about it and stuff like that
it's not like zany or wacky it's not
even i don't even know if i'd call it a
comedy it's sort of a dark comedy in the
sense that there's funny stuff in it but
it's essentially i don't even i'm not
even sure what i'd call it it's kind of
like a drama but i don't know it's not
even really that either because that
seems also kind of a reductive term i
guess most of uh jim jarmusch's movies
are kind of hard to classify so this is
another one that's like that it
definitely has elements of drama it has
elements of
you know horror even a little bit it has
elements of a comedy but it's not really
any of those things and like trying to
put it into one genre
is really doing it a disservice but yeah
this was like i just really really
thought this movie was like i don't know
fun is the exact work i guess it sort of
is it is a fun movie it's just kind of
one of those lay back on a saturday
night and like kind of get some booze or
whatever smoke some weed or whatever and
just like chill out and like watch it
and just be like yeah man it's just like
one of those kind of movies light some
candles and [ __ ] and it's like and i
really like those kind of movies you
have to be in the mood for them but this
one was definitely kind of ticked all
boxes of like stuff that i really like
it's like i said i'm not a i'm not a
giant fan i have to say of vampire
movies in general
especially like kind of uh newer ones
but even older ones i'm just kind of
like vampire's not really my favorite
monster but i just like that they were
vampires in this for a reason of
exploring
you know taking like i said looking at
history and progress through the lens of
people that were actually there like
looking into mortality immortality so
saying things about humans by
you know using the trope of
immortal
beings and not humans so i thought that
was like actually really cool so like i
said this came out in 2013. if you're
into jim jarmusch and you haven't seen
this one uh this is definitely i mean
he's got a lot of good ones but man this
one was like really really good i really
liked this a lot
it's just like the whole vibe of it i
just really dug it and uh so yeah if you
haven't seen it it's on amazon prime i'm
sure it's you know so if you have an
amazon prime subscription you can watch
it for free um i think you can watch it
like you can rent it on youtube and [ __ ]
like that too i'm sure but uh yeah you
should definitely check it out if you
like vampire movies if you like these
kind of like weird indie
kind of stuff because i feel like it
took a really long time for this to get
made like
because he couldn't get financing uh and
i guess i was reading that it took him
like seven years before they got it made
or something like that and then finally
like there was a german production
company that gave him some of the money
and then you know i know he finally got
around to making it but it seems like it
got really really good actually you know
what i i don't think i've seen a a
negative review of this um you know
because it's just
it like i said if you know what you're
getting into uh it's a really really
entertaining
uh movie and it's just and and the um
and tilda swinton and tom hiddleston
who's hottest [ __ ] in this by the way um
actually i mean they both are but they
really like play off each other really
well so like the acting is like really
great and it's you know it's just like a
really fun entertaining
just hangout
type of movie like hang out with some
weed and some lights and candles and
[ __ ] like that that type of movie uh but
yeah definitely check it out if you
haven't seen it and i will see you guys
on the next one
bye